beat is a build tool and development
server designed specifically for modern
web development it helps with fast and
efficient building and bundling of
JavaScript applications hey folks my
name is isagan I help developers to
learn front-end Technologies you should
also check out my Instagram where I post
tips tricks code Snippets related to web
Technologies so talking about learning
objectives what we are going to learn in
this tutorial is we will start with what
is wheat the very Basics and then we
will move on to why to use it what makes
it fast and what are the reasons that
you should pick feed as compared to any
other front end too and then moving on
we will learn about what are the
features that we offer and then how to
create a static JavaScript project using
wheat how to initialize view react and
sweat projects using the predefined
templates also how to integrate teguin
into your JavaScript and react.js
applications how to use environment
variables in wheat how to apply your
wheat projects to GitHub Network file
and Versa lastly how to configure your
vgs projects so all of this in this just
one single video and if you want to skip
to a specific part for example you have
the basic idea of it but you want to
learn about configuration so you can
simply jump to the configuration part
and skip the rest of the tutorial or if
you want to learn about deployments so
you can jump to the deployment section
so with that let's get started
foreign
wheat can be used as a replacement for
your create react app that is because
wheat is quick to set up it takes a few
seconds blazing fast keyboard regardless
of the app size support for multiple
Frameworks such as view sweat Etc out of
the box support for typescript jsx and
CSS and many more features
in terms of technical knowledge this
course is for beginners having a greater
understanding of Technologies such as
create react app react View and angular
is more than enough to use wheat you
need to have the node version of at
least 4.18 however this depends on the
templates some require a higher version
of node.js but for most of them you can
go for 14.18 and keep in mind that this
minimum requirement of 14.18 is at the
time of making of this video maybe in
the future it may change to some other
version and another example is let's say
we actually has used a new version and
the minimum node requirement is version
15. so in that case you will need
version 15 and not 14.18
wheat is known for being super fast
especially when it comes when you
compare it with create react app that is
because create react app will download
many dependencies including webpack
which takes a lot of time comparing that
to wheat it takes a few seconds because
wheat only makes the project structure
to install dependencies you have to do
npm install but the good thing is with
wheat there are only few dependencies
making the process quick which means no
webpack we have seen bundle Skype
webpack and parcel helping us with our
projects however as our project size
increases we notice degrees when
spinning up our developers development
server or hot recording that is because
of the increasing dependencies resulting
in the bundle doing the heavy lifting
and taking the time to spin up servers
all hot record them this quickly affects
the developers productivity which makes
very good use of the browser features
such as the native JavaScript modules in
the browser to skip the bundle part and
and use the browser support to make the
process fast to understand this more
here is how it works in create react app
so in this case everything is Blended
together and served to the browser and
by everything I mean all of the gloves
and modules this is very time consuming
and makes a hot recording very slow on
the other hand when working with wheat
only the required code is served and
processed wheat uses the dynamic import
and on the records the gout and modules
that needs to be reloaded this technique
makes wheat project fast regardless of
the app size so now that you have the
basic idea of what feed is what are the
features of it and what makes it
different or fast as compared to the
other front and tools like create react
app let's type into the Hands-On and see
how can we create projects using wheat
how can we deploy them to GitHub to
pulsar and to notify and how can we
configure our wheat projects
all right let's talk about how to create
a static server just a simple plain
JavaScript and HTML website using read
first thing first that we need to do is
to add wheat in as a project dependency
so for that what we need to do is npm
install beat
all right we have wheat install and if
we go to the project.json we can see it
here so with that let's create an
index.html file here and add something
here so for example hello world
save this and now we want to start the
server
um so for that we need to go to
package.json this should be
add
add scripts and in the scripts for now
we only need one script that is Dev
which stands for development so this is
to start a development server so for
that we will do weight Tab and that's it
so now let's try this and for that npm
gun Dev and over server is started so
let's see that in the browser all right
we have our server started and running
and as you can see this here in the
browser let me also open the inspect
agreements uh and maybe console so yeah
with that
um so we have our server started so next
thing is let's try to add JavaScript
here so let me make main.js and for now
let's simply go with console log hello
world save that and then go back to
index.html and then here one thing to
keep in mind is uh to make things simple
and to remove extra editors I am not
adding a lot of tags that I need to do
when I'm actually working on a project
for example you had text body tags uh
those HTML tags Etc that is to make
things simple and to remove extra
details but when you're working on an
actual project you need to add those
details or add those extra tags not
extras add those compulsory tags and
necessary tax so with that uh next thing
is we need to add script so you know
this that in JavaScript in in HTML if
you want to link a Javascript file we go
with the script so here it in the usual
way is this main.js but we're not going
to do it with this one and also there is
one attribute that we need to add here
otherwise this we do need few things
that will not work
um Let me let me show you that right now
before we fix this and add that one
attribute that we need so
here this works right now as you can see
Hello word but let's say that we have
multiple files here so let's say file.js
and we export something from this file
um maybe an object and we call this we
have a value inside that that is hadak
Dev and save this so save this and then
uh let me resize this uh a little bit so
yeah we save this and then go to Main
and High
import
file from dot slash file we save this
and you can see cannot use import
statement outside a module so why is
that that is because this module import
will not work until unless we set the
type to module for this script and that
is very simple and easy thing to do so
type equals to module save this
and now we go back to the main.js and
add
concert.org
file
and save this
and now you can see this works so we
have our uh we have our value equals to
correct F so that that that
so that type equals to module makes it
work and another way is even if you do
not want to go with this one there is
also another way just to show you so
that is import
dot slash main.js or maybe just main.js
uh oops yeah that will not work so Dot
scratch main.js and now this is behaving
the exact same way as it was when we add
Source like this so both ways work
um basically this portion between this
section between the script starting in
the ending tags this is uh about uh this
section is for JavaScript so we can
either add JavaScript here or we can add
our JavaScript here so both ways work
for but for now let me
let me let me add it here and then
eventually we can move out of that to
the main and also I do not need the file
so let me delete the file for now
and let me also remove it from here all
right uh so that is about how you can
add uh how you can connect Javascript
file with your index.html so that is
about JavaScript and index.html but what
about CSS so for that let's uh make
something here with name star.css and H1
here and then here equals to Blue uh not
Blue Tomato for some reason I like
tomato using in using tomato in
tutorials and then go back to index.html
and something we already know and been
using this so link
CSS and style save this
and we can see now this is working
if I now go to sources Nar sources if I
go to elements and
how about on this click on this and you
can see the style tomato and then here
we have star.css so this is the this is
that style but
yeah so this is yeah so this is uh to
add style to add CSS to your project but
if you have worked way to react.js you
may know the concept of mod use like CSS
modules and the concept of of CSS
modules is sometimes we may have a lot
of uh CSS classes and since we are using
we have reusable components and uh we
are doing a lot of imports exports Etc
we might end up with similar classes and
that may might give us conflict so to
fix that we have a concept known as CSS
modules
um but if you know if you already know
about that so nothing much to explain
here and so that's the guy let's see how
can we do that so for that style Dot
module.css and then here I am going to
copy the code from star.css
paste it here save this and then go back
to my index.html
and then here I cannot do like this
module dot CSS this works but this is
not what you want
um for example let me show you what what
I mean by this works but this is not how
we want it so rather than H1 we give it
tighter we save this
and then go back here and then give this
class equals to Tita
you see
this is not working but if I go here and
then add dot writer here save this and
then go back to
HTML and remove dot module and we save
this now this works so which means that
it works for start.css but it does not
work for style dot module.css okay so
why then we are using star dot module so
let's talk about that and let's fix that
so we will comment this code and then go
to the JavaScript section and here
import classes
from
style dot module dot CSS
and keep in mind classes is not a
keyword this could be anything depending
on whatever name you want to give it to
for example I can also give it to
styling I can give it the name starting
or start classes or anything anything
works and Technical status data reserved
keyword so with that save this
and then do console.gov
glasses
and when we save this and we go to the
console we can see this here that it has
this object here title and this value
here so what exactly that is so that is
this title and here that this title
stands for the class name and then we
have a unique sequence and then the
guide number so this one stands for the
guy in the
um to here is another example so body
and maybe anything here because we are
not using this
blue save this and now here we have
another
value another property body that is
equal to body the class name a unique
sequence and then the guy number that is
five all right and uh now the question
is how to use it so unfortunately we
cannot use it like this uh as you can
already see we have that writer but this
is not working here and like one way is
to like for example if I refresh this
if I keep refreshing this it's always
um the number the unique number is I was
same for the title
um so one way is to like if I
copy this
and if I paste this here let's see if
that works save this and yeah it worked
but when we are making an application we
cannot do this this is not a uh an
applicable solution we cannot save this
and console work the classes and then
check for that and then copy that and
then paste them here this is not
something that we need uh this is not
something that will work so what we need
to do here is we remove the class here
from here and we can add the class
dynamically in using JavaScript so for
that document dot very selector and then
we select over H1 tag and then class
name equals to
classes Dot classes dot tighter
and we save this and we have it here
hello now if I go to the arguments if I
go click on this you can see here we
have that Dynamic regenerated class name
and here we have style so if I click on
Style
it gives me this style which is this
star dot module.css so that is how you
can dynamically generate classes class
names and then and and then add them to
your HTML and connect them with your
customers so of course you need a
JavaScript for this but that is how it
works and yeah so that is the basic idea
or and that is a very basic server now
we can copy all of this except for the
first import main copy this we move this
and then
here we can just simply do source that
would be main Dot
that would be
main.js and save this go back to console
we have however that works perfect and
then just simply add these two things
and of course import should be odd at
the top and let's just do some effecting
all right now this is working so
this is a very basic uh static server uh
just a simple JavaScript HTML and
CSS now you may be wondering if there is
a quick way to start with this project
like if there is a template to spend
less time on configuration and starting
with the ball upgrade so yes the answer
is yes there is a template that you can
use and let's see how we can use the
vhci to generate something similar to
this
so for that let's move to the next
section where we can talk about how can
we use a CI to generate similar template
without starting from scratch all right
we have our new project here and this is
a completely empty folder nothing here
as you can see here and the project name
is vinegar dot dash feed so what we need
to do here is we type npm create weight
and enter this now it's going to ask us
a few questions so first thing is
Project name so since we are already in
the project we made up project so if I
go with wheat project it will create a
new product for us but what I want is I
do not want a new folder what I want is
to create to create the project inside
this folder here so I will remove this
and I will just add dot so dot means
that it should be generated in this
folder without creating a new folder and
then here we have the options of which
for which project we want to we will
discuss some other options but for now
we are going to we are going to go with
vinegar and JavaScript and that's it so
we have that same process generated here
and first thing first that if we
need to do is you can see we have the
dev dependency read but there is no node
modules so which means that if I try
these commands this will not work as you
can see npm1 Dev
this does not work and the reason for
that is we do not have the notebook use
this problem this dependency is not
installed so let's simply and quickly
install this npm install
so now if if I do it again npm gun Dev
this will work now as you can see here
um but if before opening this let's uh
get a good idea of what files we have so
index.html something we had previously
we created from scratch and then here
script type module Source main.js
exactly the way that we did and then we
have the main folder here which is like
importing Styles
um so it's not using the modules but
still this we we also did something like
this if you want to convert it to
modules we will be doing
um classes and then style dot module and
then we also have to fix the name here
in here but uh there should be four but
for now let's not do this because you
already got the idea so
yeah and and if you if we have to do
this we have to make uh multiple changes
here so then we have the index.html and
then we have the public folder which has
the assets so in this case it's uh the
SVG of the V so let's uh start server
and let's we already have started this
particles all right so here is the
server and this is the server generated
using the create other template so that
is how you can start with your boy
upgrade uh using the template that is
given to us by wheat and feel free to
make any changes depending on your
project so that is it for this section
uh with that let's move on to the next
section on uh how can we skip those all
of those questions we had that was the
project name and uh the type Etc and if
there is a way to quickly generate this
project or the power create uh the
template without going through all of
those questions and yes there is a way
so let's let's learn that so what we
need to do uh is we type npm
create
white and then my Js app then dash dash
template now if you're using npm 7 plus
version 7 plus you do need some extra
dashes here if you're using npm 6.x then
it is fine you do not need need these
dashes but if you are on version 7 or
above you do need these extra dashes and
then template and then the template
should be vinegar
and we have our setup here so let's open
this and see what we have inside code
mygs app and here you can see we have
the exact same setup so we just skipped
all of those questions
similarly we we are going to talk more
about this but if in case Cuts you want
to go for uh make a view JS application
so for that npm create feed my view app
again extra dashes and then template
View
and let's see this so maybe just go
inside this in the terminal and let's
see uh we have index package.json
Etc
uh let's see the practice.json here and
you can see here it has view in it so
that is how you can use the templates
without going through all of those
questions by just using some extra
arguments in the command guide
all right now we already know about the
template CLI commands um so let's try to
use that for uh making a react chess
application so for that I again have a
new folder and a new project and that is
a computer empty project with the name
react.wipe react dash feed so what I
need to do here is one way is to go with
npm create create feed but what I will
do here is npm create wheat Dash Dash
and dashes template again
notice that I've add a DOT here
otherwise this should be like my app or
something and then last thing here is
let me add a DOT and then the last thing
here is the template should be react and
let's see yes we have the package and
this is a react application and if I do
npm install
so this is the last step and once we are
done with this we have our react
application all set up and see how
notice how easy it is to create a react
application with v and like create
reactive which takes almost a Whole
Decade to create a basic project so we
have this our setup and uh this will not
work because this is from the previous
project
um that we created but gets Sky npmgun
Dev and let's see what we have here and
yeah we have our uh wheat plus react
application so that is how simple it is
to make over uh basic react application
um so yeah with that uh let's move on
towards understanding how we can
integrate tag event uh we are going to
first try with the simple vinegar JS
application the static application and
then we are going to move back to this
project that we just created and add
event CSS to this one as well so uh
let's uh open that other project that we
created previously
so this is a web project and what we
need to do here is uh we first need to
start the dev server
um so that I can refresh this and here
you can see this so to add payment here
what we need to do here is first thing
first uh we will again we will stop the
server for now clear this and then here
we need to add a bunch of things here so
first thing is npm install we basically
need to install a bunch of dependencies
um so of course Taiwan CSS and then post
CSS and then Auto prefix
so let's install this and once we
install these dependencies then we need
to do npx David CSS
init which stands for initial guys and
net P so this adds this
divin.config dot CGS now we are almost
set up uh another thing that we need to
do is
um so this is something you can get from
the table and CSS website but we need to
import the payment components uh the
table and classes so go to this go to
the style.css uh any of your CSS class
and then add these tablet base
different components
they should replace different components
and then they went utilities and that is
it so now we are done with this
um then it's almost set up so let's try
let's let's see if this works npm gun
Dev notice that we have a warning and
then there was slight change in the
structure let's see if the CSS
components of David is working so for
that I need to go to the main.js because
we have something here and then get me
Chi
cross equals to text Dot Maybe 2xi
and save this
and you can see it did not work if I
even if I go for 6xi it's not working
um maybe I can try pg Dash black and
text Dash white nothing works and the
why is that
um the reason for that is if I again
start the server there is this warning
the content option in your table and CSS
configuration is missing or empty so
let's go to the time in config so this
content should have are the files where
we want to apply our Styles so let's add
that let's for now we
have this index.html and we don't have
anything here but we will also include
this file so index.html
and then for now it depends on how you
want to use this but for now I am going
to include all of my JavaScript files so
uh dot slash
stag.js and save this and the moment I
save this you can see the change
happened here so I have a bit with the
background black background and white
text and if I go back here and then if I
change this to let's say 3xi
this works but 6xl looks pretty good
then we add some padding just to show
you so PX 4 and py2
and we can see it has spreading so yeah
that is how it works and we have
successfully integrated and added tape
and CSS to a vinegar are static
um website app so with that let's move
on to a reactor supplication and let's
see how we can add it there as well it's
it's almost exactly the same but let's
see how we can do that all right back to
react.js application created with wheat
um npm1 Dev and refresh this and we have
this uh so let's see how we can
integrate turbine into this so for that
again I'm going to stop the server for
now and then again install all those
packages so they went CSS post CSS and
auto we fix it it's a side thing a side
note uh this this documentation is
already available on the table and CSS
official website so you can also check
it out from there as well and then we
have this installed so let's also go
with Degen CSS init Dash p which we
install the tavin config file here and
again we need to add our
configuration we need to and again we
need to add the files that we want to be
included for the classes so here it's
going to be index.html and then another
one is going to be Source forward slash
extract and then static Dot
Dot and then we have to include multiple
extensions here so that is JS DS jsx and
TSX
depending on what extensions we are
using so this one is all about GSX so we
can remove typescript extensions
and even to be more specific we can also
just include
dot jsx but it depends on how what are
what are the extensions you're using but
this basically means that go to the
source and then maybe something that
exists here or maybe something that
exists in a file and then Dot GSX uh
static jsx means that anything dot TSX
so that encodes app.jsx as well as
main.jsx so with that let's uh
uh yeah one more thing that we need to
do is to import the classes for uh the
index dot to to the index.css so
go to the index.css and then again tag
event
base
components and then the event utilities
and that is it save this and now let's
start the server and be I'm going to Dev
we see the change in the in the images
so that means that something happened
here
um we have no utility classes were
detected in your source file so let's
see a what exactly is happening here
uh
yeah this should be the Google practical
entertainment so in wagon so maybe let's
fix this
and that is what it wants us to do stop
the server start it again
let's see if this work if it does not
then maybe we can just remove this one
so maybe add it here
um again for the H1 BG dash pack let's
see if it works yep it is working
so yeah
text white and text Dash
6xl or maybe 5xl
and yep that is how we can add our HTML
classes
um and and yep that is how we can add
our different classes and maybe I can go
to my index.css uh maybe yeah so we move
the
padding
so I maybe remove all of these values
and we have we can then just go with
different classes but that is how it
works
um and then that other warning you can
ignore that for now so yep that is how
you can integrate CSS into your react
yes application so with that let's move
on towards the next section
all right let's understand how
environment forgiveness Works in wheat
and to do so let's first understand the
theory behind it in wheat there are
multiple environment variables and fast
for example a simple dot EnV file loads
in all cases and uh dot EnV dot local
also goes in all cases but is ignored by
git
simulator.env dot mode on records in a
specific mode in this case the mode
stands for development of production and
r dot
env.mod.co also loads in a specific mode
but is ignored by git so let's see that
in action so for example we create this
new file dot EnV now this file is the
file that environment variables that we
have in this file we got in all cases
for example if I type something here and
also to keep in mind that whenever you
are adding an environment variables you
need to have a prefix that is white
underscore test otherwise this will not
work I will give you unexpected issues
the next thing is we have this another
environment for you by that is env.goker
there is not much difference between
this dot EnV and Dot EnV local except
the except that this dot env.hoker will
be ignored by gate 4. so for example if
you have some sensitive data let's say
some API key or something similar so you
can add all of that here for example
here we can add DB name and then some
something here and then under white and
wheat and score DB pass and then also
add something here password
and save this
now the question is how can we use this
in uh in our JavaScript for example if
you use node.js so it's in node.js it's
something like this node underscore
process underscore node underscore EnV
but in case of Feed the way to use it is
import dot meta dot EnV and if I save
this and I go back to my console and in
the console I can see these things here
so let me resize my window I'll get a
bit
so here I can see uh we test as run and
then wheat DB name something and we DB
uh pass something now and I also have
some other variables that is Dev Mode
God
Etc
um let's talk about that in a second but
in this case if I commit this and push
this to GitHub this we test wheat
underscore test will be sent to GitHub
and committed by kit but the wheat
underscore DB name and wheat underscore
DP password big no because that exists
in this env.worker let's talk about
these Dev mode dot SSR Etc so these are
some properties and we can use that to
get an idea for example if I want to see
that if this is a development server or
a production server and based on that
decision we want to make some decision
so we can do something like this so
let's say we do console log
solo
is running in and then import dot meta
dot EnV dot mode
I believe this is mode uh yes but this
should be
mode
and save this so you can see Server is
getting in development similarly we can
also do something like if
if you want to let's say check that if
based on like the mode we want to make a
specific decision if it's in development
server we have a specific scenario and
we want to make a specific decision and
if it's a production server we want to
make another specific decision so for
that case import dot meta dot EnV Dot
Dev
and then console.org
this is Dev server
and also let me do console log
import dot meta dot EnV and save this so
like you can see this here this is Dev
server that is because this is two
because we are in the dev server open
this and in this case Dev is to go
because we are using wheat Dev if we do
weed build so that will be production
and then in that case mode will be
production and this period will be true
and this one will be fast so these are
exactly opposite when Dev is to God is
false and when God is 2 Dev is fast
um so similarly the base URL is the base
UI in SSR stands for server side again
so this is pretty simple now let's move
on to another example
um so let's say we have EnV Dot plot dot
dot local
and this should be dot EnV and let's say
that let me see why this did not work
EnV dot dot
dot okay
so maybe we can change this for now for
testing uh we can change this to dot Dev
and let's see this so white underscore
sum underscore key equals to uscon and
let's test this now so if I open this
do we have it
do we have it nope we don't have it
let's remove this and then check this
again all right um this is probably
because we are writing it wrong so this
should be in V Dot development and let's
see this again
and now we have it white underscore read
underscore sum underscore key equals and
similarly if I change this to
dot local and then save this again
refresh this this also still works we
didn't score some underscore key equals
to run now if I change this to
production
and close all of these messages and save
this now in this case
we still don't have anything that is
because this will work for the
production but this does not work for
environment figures and it's uh to get
these values it's the same as
import.meter.env and underscore
something so maybe change it here dot uh
read underscore sum underscore key but
this will not work for production so
let's revert it back to development and
once we save this we flash this we have
some key here we have a second here uh
that is the value of v d underscore sum
underscore key so the the way to get it
is the same as the way to get anything
from dot EnV the only difference is the
file name so that is how it works for uh
the different modes now talking about
learning priorities in EnV variable for
a specific mode takes a higher priority
than a generic one so to show you that
for example we have this here and I'll
copy this and do this again here but in
this case I change the Swagger to
haddock and save this now let's see what
we get here we still get S1 that is
because this one will take and has
higher priority as compared to this one
or this one because this is more
specific so the more specific will give
us takes higher priority than the
generic ones moreover uh variables added
the script have the highest priority for
example if I go to my package.json and
then here I type something let's say
white we again go with the same key
white underscore sum underscore key and
set this to uh attack Dev and save this
and stop the server start it again so
let's see what we get there so now we
get product F that is because this one
has the highest priority and then the
more specific environment variable
sketch the higher priority and then the
US priority is for these generic
environment variables so that is how you
can use environment variables in wheat
and all of the different modes and how
of the different priorities for the
variables in wheat so with that let's
move on to what's the next section
alright folks let's talk about how to
deploy our applications and in this
section we are going to talk about how
to deploy it to GitHub how to deploy it
to netifi and also how to deploy it to
versa so let's start with GitHub the
first thing that you need to do is you
need to have a project and in this case
I again created a new template and this
is a vanaga JavaScript template which
means that this is a static website so
first thing first I am going to do is I
will do npm install to install other
repositories other dependencies and once
we are done with this uh before we move
on towards deployment section there is
one thing I want to talk about and that
is how to make a build so for that what
you need to do is
if I go to package.json there you can
see there is a build and a preview
command so bit stands for making the
production version so if I do npm build
you can see a desk folder so uh if I
want to check this so what I need to do
is I want to I need to do npm gun
preview and this will start the server
for us so if I open this you can see
this server and you can see this website
um something we already know and we did
this before so let's get back and one
other thing is let's say I do not want
this
44173 port so what I can do here is I
can give it a custom Port that is port
8080 save this and then again do npm1
preview and this will give us the Goku
host with 8080 so uh that is how to test
it so once you're done with testing your
website locally testing in the build
version then the next part is to deploy
it on GitHub pages so for that what I
need to do is I have to make a GitHub
reposit and for that I will go to my
GitHub and there create a new repository
here so maybe go here and then click on
new Repository
and then I will name this wheat GitHub
and select myself here nothing to do
here and then click on create capacity
so we have a simple repository what I
need next is I need to push out the code
to GitHub this is pretty simple these
are pretty simple steps you already know
this I assume so I'll clear the console
and then initialize git and then add all
of these and then last thing is
initial commit
all right now the thing is
if this was uh so in this case this is
going to be wheat GitHub but uh which
means that this is going to be
eventually uh
dot attack dot GitHub dot IO forward
slash wheat Dash GitHub so this will be
our repository
um this will be our depart website but
if this was not the case and we had
something like this
product.dev.github.io which means that
this capacity was named as productive so
in that case we do not need to do
anything but in this case this is going
to be uh V Dash GitHub so that is the
repository name so for that we need to
also change our path so that when it
uploads and when we deploy the server
when you deploy the website it is
zipcard at it is deployed in we Dash
GitHub so for that what we need to do is
to have wheat config file so that is
feed Dot config.js and then here I need
to do Define config here and then export
default Define config
this is a function and then this
function accepts uh object so objects so
first thing here is base so base stands
for the base path where this path will
be so in this case by default the base
path is this which means that nothing uh
just a simple scratch so the reason uh
that you do not need to modify it if if
this is forward sketch product Dev so
that will be eventually this one hotel
dev.github.io so nothing here and that
is the default part but in this case it
is going to be wheat Dash GitHub so
which means that we have to modify our
base path
to make sure that everything work so
what I need to do is this should be read
GitHub and also have forward slash so
save this and if I now again do npm1
build and let's see this so npm1 preview
and now you can see this that the path
is totally different so it's sweet
GitHub so let's go there now here is the
problem uh we have the JavaScript logo
working but the wheat Coco is not
working so a quick fix for this is and
this is something to keep in mind when
you have in a different path and so this
currently it has aggregate of path and
this will not work because the reason
for this is this is if I click on this
and open this in a new tab this is
basically not using wheat Dash GitHub
here so the issue here is the long path
and the fix for this is if I do V Dash
GitHub and then forward scratch now this
works so to fix this what we can do is
we can make this an absolute path like
this and save this we start with server
uh make the build again and then again
do preview
and let's see this now so now this works
so that is to keep in mind that it
should be absolute path not the greater
path and the reason that JavaScript Coco
works is that because we are using
import here we just tested our build
version locally so everything works good
so let's stop this
get add and then we just updated the
path
rated path and then get push origin Main
uh get push origin mean
whoops get push origin mean yeah this is
because
we did not copy this
so we have to set this and then get
personal reason Main
now let's go back here refresh this
and we have our project here so let's uh
talk about how can we now make a GitHub
page here so go to settings and then go
to pages
and then here we are going to go with
GitHub actions
and here in this case since this is a
static HTML file so we will go with this
option static HTML configure now here
are we have to do a couple of things
here and if in case you forget this you
can always get this in the whatever
changes I'm making you can always get
this from read documentation but what we
need to do here is uh this is just
setting pages and uploading artifacts
and all those things but the thing here
is this is a wheat project which means
that there are some dependencies if this
was a simple HTML project then we do not
need to make any changes here but this
is a wheat project and it has some
configuration basically npm install and
read build and read preview that you can
see here so we need to add these things
so for that what we need to do is
let me Zoom this a bit so that we can
see this maybe just a little bit more
and
yeah so what we need to do here is we
need to add a few more actions here so
steps here so for that I will add a new
name and this one is going to be set up
node
and then here it is going to be uses
actions forward slash setup Dash node at
V3 and then the next thing is with that
so the width basically means that with
which node version I want it to be so
this is going to be 18 and then cash
equals to this one is npm then the next
thing is we have
install dependencies so once we set up
our node version we need to install
dependencies
and the command for this is npm install
and then once we install dependencies so
something we already did in our local
server so then the next thing is we need
to build the dependencies build the
project so this one is going to be build
project uh a bit so the name is
basically the action name what a step
name what we are doing and it could be
anything it's up to you how you define
it and then this one is Run npm Gun
build and I believe that is it so yeah
we need to build it and then we need to
set up Pages Etc now one other thing is
if I go back to the server uh if I go
back to the visual studio code when we
do npm gun bid it makes the project in
the dist folder so we need to also
change that here so upload entire
apostrophe path is going to be forward
slash dist and that's it so that we save
this
we don't do anything here because this
is just a test file and save this and
then go to actions
and here we have the action so let's go
there and let's see what's happening and
click on deploy
it's gonna take a few seconds
so I will fast forward this
all right it looks like something is not
working and let's see that so setup node
unable to find node version 18 comma for
platform index now I know what the
problem is so we made a small mistake
here so let's go back to the GitHub
actions workflow and then static.yaml
and the problem here is let me edit this
the problem here is this is not no 18
comma this is just 18 otherwise it will
create it as 18 comma and that is not
what we what version we want so save
this and then let's go back to GitHub
actions update static.camwell and then
click on deploy and let's wait for this
all right the deploy has been successful
so let's go back to the actions and
click on this update actions and then
click on this link and here we can see
our web page and this is successfully
working and we also have the wheat
Google as well as the JavaScript that is
how you can deploy your wheat
application to GitHub using GitHub
actions and GitHub pages so now let's
move on towards the net KFI version all
right let's talk about how to deploy our
code to network I just like we did it on
GitHub and for this I made a new project
and this is again uh and this is again a
template and a static JavaScript project
so for that what we need to do first is
I have to install I have to initialize
git and I have to commit all those files
so initial guys uh I may be initial
commit
and whoops I have to put codes all right
with that let me go to my GitHub and uh
make a new Repository I will call this
uh no template product Dev and this is
named as Network
let me see what name I have here so this
is sweet net cafe so wheat Dash net cafe
and create repository all right copy
this and simply push the code so this is
get
not get just paste this and then get
push origin Main
all right so we simply post the code so
this was the very simple step we press
the page and we can see things here all
right so for the next thing what we need
to do is uh we need to add we need to
add net file CLI this is the npm package
that we need let me Zoom this bit so
this is the package that we need and I
think I have already installed this but
let me try installing this again so and
and keep in mind that you have to
install this um I'm going to install
this with Dash G which means that it's a
globally installed so I can access this
anywhere so for that it's npm install
Network
C and this might not work so I am gonna
do with sudo command and I will add my
password
and this will install this so let's uh
wait for the installation and once
installation completes it can move on
with the next steps all right it is
installed so let's try Netflix I
init but before that what you need to do
is you need to do Network file login
um if I just do Network I
it will probably give us commands so
it's going I will have to do sudo notify
because I installed this using sudo so
yeah it gives us other commands that we
can use so first thing first is that you
need to use Network file login so that
it can log into your account and for
that it will open the browser for you
and you have to login your account I
think I since I already installed this
so I am already logged in so I am not
going to do that step but I will go with
netify init which will initialize
Network app project here so connect this
with uh to a new to an existing
rectifier directory Network site nope
create and configure new set yes because
I want to create a new set
um so in my network file this is my team
and site name so I'm gonna give this
blank so that Network generates its own
domain and and the link for me and that
will be line up so select that uh
nothing here and create it so
um yeah we have these links here we can
see that but let's first finish the
setup your bit commands
um so by default it's going to be read
built and yeah that is that is exactly
what you want uh depart to the current
directory dist so yeah that will be test
and
known that if I detected what you like
one just simply yes and which means that
we don't need to make any changes here
to keep things simple we have it so
let's uh go back and let me go to
network.com and login here
and let's see what we have it so uh if I
move back we have so you can see here
site created and the URL is this
adorable style guides if I open this
I can see Hello wheat and this is
perfectly working everything is working
and if I go back to my uh
if I go back to my Netflix I can see
that here adorable guides and you can
see ghost published was 11 21 so yeah
which means that we have successfully
deployed our application to network file
and this is very simple as compared to
uh GitHub using GitHub actions and
GitHub pages so yeah our website is live
and here it is uh if you want you can
also change the domain for this one and
for that you need to go to The Domain
settings and add your domain here but
that's out of the scope of this so we
are not gonna do any changes here and if
I go to site settings and then if I go
for build and deploy you can see
currently policy this is the capacity
that we have in this one and another
thing is uh build command is wheat build
purpose directory is dist and or
production branch is me now one another
good thing is if I make any changes here
if I push any let me Zoom this a bit if
I push anything to my GitHub repost key
to we destined foreign
get up actions for me and it will update
um it will update this for me so which
means that I do not need to manually
update this just like we had in GitHub
action so every time we make any changes
the GitHub actions guns and it updates
our website for us so similarly in net
profile as well it will update us it
will update it so yeah that is how we
can deploy our application to net
profile we can deploy our wheat
application to network with that let's
move on to Virtual and let's see how can
we
our project to us all right again
another new apostrophe and another new
project that is static static JavaScript
so uh I am again going to repeat those
same steps that is get in it and then
commit this and then push this code so
this will be initiate commit I am fast
forwarding this because we already just
did this twice um so let me create the
browser so be it Versa and create the
capacity and then copy this and then
push the code so get push origin mean
all right we just pushed the code and if
I refresh this uh we have the code here
so with that uh what we need to do is uh
we for the previous Network example we
installed Network file that was 95-ci
but for this I am going to install Voice
um and that is like this uh net KFI npm
install Versa G and I think I have
already installed this but let's try
this again and probably this will not
work because I have to do this with sudo
but let's see if this is installed or
does this work okay so this is not
working and that is because I have to
give sudo here um so let me I think I
already have installed this but let me
just do this again so I will add my
password here and get me then fast
forward the video all right now what we
need to do next is we just simply do
sudo versus and set up and deploy yes we
have to deploy this so this is the path
uh
and yes this is y and then which scope
do you want to deploy it to contact f
going to an existing project nope I want
a new project what's your
[Music]
what's your project name wheat person
and in which directory is your code
located so this is the current directory
so I will not add anything here setting
up your project
all right I want to modify these
settings nope because these settings
looks pretty good because output
directory is disk yep install commands
npm install deployment we test a spot
part and bid command feedback so yeah
all things go good no
all right it created this get ignore and
as well as this sourcer and we have the
production here and get let's click on
this open this
and we can see our web page so with that
let me go to versa
and let's see if we have our website
there so Versa and then here we have it
so this is the website if I go back and
here we can see the website waitverse if
I click on this and here this is
if I go back
um this is the link read Versa and
here to confirm this we have V Dash
versus
dot app and this is the same link meet
Dash versus DOT log dash dot Versa dot
app so yeah that is the same thing and
this was created one minute ago by me so
so that is how to deploy your website to
Versa and uh pretty simple pretty easy
and very straightforward so that was
about uh deployment
all right so by now we have covered a
lot of things that includes how to start
your server how to make your projects
and what exactly is feed and how to
deploy your projects and a lot of many
things but there is one other important
thing that is configuration so we are
going to talk about how to configure
your wheat project I have again made a
new content and uh first thing first I
am going to install all the dependencies
and again this is a static JavaScript
project and I am using that project I
chose that project to make things simple
so no reactors few JS Etc so I installed
my packages and if I do npm um oops not
npm install if I do npm Dev it starts
the server for me and yeah everything is
working so I clear this and I stop the
server and clear this all right
um so to con so to add configuration
what you need to do is you need to
activate a new file and with the name
feed dot config dot Js
and um maybe I can zoom in
um and yeah so let me
let me size some windows okay so this is
the in empty file and this is the
configuration file and other
configurations should be in this file so
what we need to do here is the very
simple and the most basic config should
be export default and course and uh that
is a start course attacks brackets and
if I save this and if I do npm1 Dev
everything works and this is uh
technically this is uh similar to not
having this file at all because there is
no configuration at all right now and
and if I and if we move back to the
deployment specifically the GitHub
deployment using GitHub Pages we talked
about base and we talked about how to
deploy our project when the path is not
just the username dot github.io but
username.github.io forward slash
repository name so in that case what we
did was we added a base URL we added
base so in that case if you remember we
used uh something that is known as
Define config so but if in case you do
not want to go with that and I am going
to also talk about that
why we use that there are what is the
difference between that and this one the
basic one so we can also use base for
example I add base and I do wheat and
save this and then clear the console and
then again do npm1 tab so notice here we
have working host 5173 and then read so
wheat is now the base path and that is
because we change the base so which
means that it works it's it works
exactly the same way but I am will stop
the Server create the screen close this
and all right
um so close this and this and I'm going
to remove this and rather than this what
I will do is I will use import Define
config from wheat and then export
default
Define config
and brackets and then again brackets and
then here if I type base
I can see Visual Studio code giving me
suggestions so the reason are the point
of using Define config are comparing
this Define config with the most basic
config which was export default
and default and this so writing it like
this
um
it should be wheat so getting it like
this or getting it like this this is
both of these does the similar job the
difference is
in this basic we do not get any
Integrations
so if I type base nothing nothing
happens the space is because we already
declared it once but in this case if I
don't have the base and I type Bas it
gives me the base and also helps me with
the what exactly is the base so it is
base public path when server and
deployment and development of production
and then it can be a string or it can be
undefined so if I now again do chords
and then wait save this and then again
npm1 def I can see 5.73 forward slash
feed so stop this Server create a screen
and uh
minimize this so which means that it the
difference here is with defined config
things get pretty much easy uh things
get super easy because we have the
integrisens giving us
giving us suggestions
all right so uh which means that um in
this case we uh in this tutorial we are
going to use the Define config but feel
free to go with the other uh basic
configuration as well it's totally up to
you all right so uh we already discussed
base and um base is something that you
already know um and if in case you have
skipped that part and you're just
watching this video for configuration so
base is basically for if in case you do
not want your file uh your project to be
hosted on the main on the home page
which means like localhost 3000 I'll go
okay host 5173 and you want it to be
hosted on at say Google host with 3000
forward slash feed so in that case the
base should be wheat okay so that is the
base now with that
um maybe you want to do something some
configuration uh some specific things in
your development server
um so let's say you want your project to
be if it is going in development if it
is going to production then you want the
base to be wheat but if it is in
development in in Dev mode you do not
want the base path
um so you can also do that and for that
what we can do here is I will remove
this and then uh what I am going to do
here is I will again
um add make this more like a function
and then here uh this accepts uh an
argument and a single argument which is
basically an object and then that object
has
um consists of three properties command
mode and SSR bid now all of these
consist in one argument but I
desstructured that here in this object
so uh we can get all of these here so if
I do console log command mode SSI bit so
let's see what it gives and then I can
talk about uh what exactly it is and how
to how to use and this will not work so
if I if I do the npm grandf this would
probably not work yes this will not work
and that is because now we converted
this into a function and it must
obviously done something so what we can
do is we can just for now we can return
an empty object and then clear the
screen and then again npm gun Def and
this should work now so let's open this
and with that we have this and let's see
what do we have in if I go to inspect
and maybe I can dock it or attach it to
the bottom and then go to console
refresh this uh nothing happens here
that is because this is not going to
appear on the website this is going to
appear here
in the terminal and that is because this
is the configuration this is not the
main.js that appears or that is rendered
on in in the browser so what we have
here command mode SSI bit so the command
itself mode is development and SSI build
as far so what does self mean so self
stands for Dev mode a development server
and build stands for production so if
this command is saved so that means that
this is a Dev mode and if this is built
then that means that this is production
maybe we can check that as well but that
is the general idea so the mode is for
now development and that makes sense if
this is if we change this and go to
window production so this will change
and then SSI bit stands for server side
grinding um
and as of now in version 3 this is an
experiment uh property so with that
let's drop the server let's see what
happens when I do npm1 build
and do we have anything here uh yes so
now you can see this is build command
turns into build and more turns into
production and SSI again is fast and
let's see now npm gun preview what we
get here again self uh because that is
now again in a development mode uh we
are just trying to uh see the
development uh so we have the production
version yet anyway just
doing the preview so that is why this
itself because we are in the dev board
uh we are in the dev and production
because this is the production version
and then again SSR is false
so with that uh now that you have the
basic out of these properties
um what happens if I
if I do so what we can do about the base
part so let's say
um I can do is if not maybe command if
mode equals to so what modes we have one
is uh
so one more that we have here is
production and the other one is document
so what I want is if this is in
production what I want is that base
should be
this should be done with the base of
power slash beat but if this is not then
we just simply do this now let's see
what happens here if I do npm gun Dev
what we get here so you could host 5.73
but if I stop the server and then npm
gun build
and then npm can preview
now what we see here is this this file
so if I click on this and open this so
now this is working and again this video
is not working and this is something
that we have already fixed in the GitHub
deployment paper when we were going for
GitHub deployment so we have already
fixed that but just to quickly let you
know how why is that happening and how
to fix this if you want to know why is
that happening you can refer back to the
GitHub deployment section but to fix
this we can just remove uh this read
from here and then
npm1 build and then npm gun
preview
and this should work now have I refresh
this yeah so again if you want to one if
you want to learn more why why is this
working this way and why not
um like this you can refer back to the
GitHub deployment section
so if I stop the server and if I do npm
gun Dev
this is now not on the not on the
forward slash wait this is on this path
and here everything is working
um so with that mode and command Etc you
can uh add some conditional conditions
so but I'm going to remove this
um maybe I should also remove this
because we do not need this and also
remove this and save this let me know if
just to make sure everything works fine
and yes everything works fine
um and that's it so yeah that is about
conditional config and based on these
settings are based on these modes you
can uh do conditional things all right
um the next thing is uh async config so
you can use async config for example
calling a third party API to get some
data that can be used in configuration
and how exactly to do that so that is
um what you can do here is you can make
this function async so basically you
pass the function in this Define config
and then here uh you restructure this
again so that is command and mode and
then here uh you do const data equals to
await and then what uh some async
function that you have
um already defined somewhere so you get
that and then based on that you return
um other information and then use this
data so you can also this is pretty much
the same thing that we did before right
this command and mode and SSI bit so we
did that but we just made this function
async and that means that uh you can
also have some async uh configuration
here and make this configuration in
async function make this function in
async function so if you have something
some third-party configurational you
have to access third party fault
configuration you can also do that and
simply make this function async by just
adding async here and then using a
weight here um you already I'm I am
assuming you have the you are familiar
with async await concept so with that
let me remove this again and this as
well and save this
all right
um so to make things simple because and
and also we do not need async at the
moment are these commands and modes so
with that uh another thing and by the
way
um there are a lot of configuration that
you can check on the on the dogs in the
docks of uh vidges but in this tutorial
I am going to go few of the most
important Accenture the most used
configuration uh to give you a good idea
of how to get started with uh
configuration I'll have to do the basic
configurations all right let's talk
about how to load environment variables
in our configuration file so for example
if we need the files for some reason so
let's see how can we do that for that
maybe first thing is we need to make an
environment variable file r dot EnV so
that we have something to import and
here I can do V Dot DB name equals to DB
name and
not wheat underscore name DB name and
then wheat underscore pass equals to DB
pass and save this maybe I can do DB
um just a name and then go back here and
for that to load them we need an import
to import something that is about EnV
and then here we need to again convert
this to a function so this function and
we need uh two things here that is uh
maybe not two things one a one and that
is mode but uh let's stay
that's a import a command and mode and
this should be in the brackets these
brackets because we are destruction in
them and then here constant V equals to
your dnv and then mode and then crosses
dot CWD so the CWD method Returns the
current working directory of the node
process so this means that this in this
case it's a returning this target key
and then we have empty codes and that
third parameter if we set that to empty
codes uh this means that to load all the
environment for viewers regardless of
wheat underscore prefix so this means
that we will get every uh applicable
environment for you but and you can see
that in a few seconds so with that let
me do console.log and then EnV and then
uh maybe here I can do return and then
empty so let's see what we get here npm
gun Dev and oops we have an unexpected
area and let's see why we have that um
the path argument must be of a type
scanning so yeah this should be like
this and let's uh see it again so yeah
this work now and let's see what we have
here so you can see that we have
everything here and if I scroll to the
top we will be able to see what we are
looking for that is wheat underscore
name wheat underscore pass
so let's see if I can adjust access with
name and pass by just doing this and
let's try again I don't know if this
will work but let's see and Yep this
works so this is a this is for the
prefix so if I type this this means that
we only get uh other variables that
start with V so that is how you can
access that and then you can use them
here
so that is for the environment variables
and then let's talk about some of the
options and for the options we do not
need to have this object we can again
convert this to
um a simple object we don't need the
function and then here we already talked
about the function let's talk about so
another important one or a simple one is
so if you have noticed whenever we do
something here it clears the screen so
for example if I if I save this and if I
create a console
um if I run npm1 Dev you see the screen
is good and we get this but if I get
safe I do not want this other it's
technically it's not cleared if I scroll
to the top I can see either data here
but let's say I do not want that so what
I can do here is
I can do clear screen equals to fast
this is 2 by default so if I do screen
first and then stop the server and let
me
resize this npm and Dev and now you can
see this is not clear and if I make a
small change here and save this you can
see nothing changed here uh I mean the
previous log is still available on the
screen so that is a very small property
that is a very simple property that you
can use and then apart from that
um in the environment for you by the
default prefix is sweet underscore that
is what what is expected but if you want
you can also change that so let's say I
want this to be uh rather than wheat I
want this to be app and for this one as
well app but for that we need to figure
configure that in
vid.config and this is EnV
prefix and then here I can I can do app
underscore and save this so now we will
have app underscore name and app
underscore password hide this so I go
here and then I type
console.org import dot meta dot EnV so
that is how you can import environment
for your bus we already talked about
this before so I saved this and I go
back I refresh this up
this is not the server the server should
be
the server should be 5173 so five
five one seven three
and I go to the inspect
and uh go to console and we size this
refresh this and then here you can see
app and it's called name and app
underscore pass so this works now all
right so that is for uh
so so that is to change the environment
for variable prefix now make sure that
you do not set it to this because that
again we might return an error and also
this means that you will be expecting a
lot of and unexpected issues so we do
not need this so let's get back to app
and let's go and then
next thing is a source map so uh if you
are working with the let's say scss then
when you load your website and when it
appears on your browser it's uh the
browser do not understand the CSS assess
or any other preprocessor it you need to
use uh you need to use something to
convert all of your code to CSS and then
that CSS is loaded here but sometimes
that CSS in in the in in the arguments
in the arguments that CSS might be a
minified version so uh to D to make it
easy for yourself to debug the issue so
what you can do is you can do CSS and
then in CSS you can do Dev Source map
and you can turn this to two so this
means that you will have the source map
if you want to enable The Source map
property if you do not know about the
source Maps basically the browser can
map C CSS generated by a p processor
such as SAS back to the source file so
it means that you will be able to trace
that specific property back to its CSS
scss SAS version so that is the property
that is the functionality of uh Source
map so if you enable this you will be
able to go back to that SAS scss file
and
exactly get that line number of the
property in scss in the browser
so that is for the source map but for
now since we are not using this so let
me skip this uh maybe comment this and
then another thing is if let's say I
want is um so there are two things one
is the server and one is the preview so
the server is when I
let me show you this so if I do server
and then if I do if I want to let's say
change the part number if I do part
and then if I do preview and then part
80 80 and save this I need a comma here
save this and then refresh this clear
screen
and
npm and build I make the build and then
npm and preview so let's see what we get
here we get 8080 that is for this one
now let me
so we get the ETD that is for the
preview and for the preview we already
set the power to 8080. so if I stop this
and if I now do npm gun Dev what we get
here we get 3000 so what do you
understand from this
um the understanding here is
that this server uh has a pod that is
set to 3000 and then we have preview
which has a part of 8080 so this means
that when we ever we execute npm gun Dev
it will use this port and whenever we do
nbm and preview it will use this part
now it may be possible that a port is
already taken by something else and in
that case what it will do is it will
take the next available port and um that
whatever that is so that will be
automatically detected and it will take
it but let's say you do not want that
and you want it to be if that Port is
taken so just close the app so what you
can do here is you can add strict pot
equals to true so if you do this
um this means that if this 8080 is not
available so do not search for the next
spot and just exit uh close the project
across the server
um so yeah that is uh what it means so
maybe what I can do is I can start
another server in the background and
then we can we can try this again all
right I started another server with the
port 3000 and uh let's see what happens
here so if I do npm gun Dev
um we can see now 3001 started because
3000 is already taken but what I if I do
strict pot equals to 2 and save this and
stop the server here
uh this might take a time so if I can
stop this and stop this and this is not
working so let me
just open a new terminal and then let's
try this so if I
set this to save this and npm I'm going
to have uh you can see what we get here
um Port 3000 is already in use but if I
comment this which means clickbot is
equals to 2 save this and then High npm
gun Dev now we have Port 3000 is in use
trying another one and then 3001 so we
get three thousand one all right so that
is uh how you can how you can State the
port number uh if you want you can leave
it and by default it's far so which
means that it will get the next part
number and with that in other thing is
uh the log level so let's say in server
um if I change if I do uh not in server
this is not a server a previous password
command so this is General command so if
I do log level and turn this to silent
and save this and let's say I set this
to 2 as well stop this so let's me let
me save this and then let's try
something here so npm.dev and uh
let me maybe stop pause this because I
was expecting it it did not work so
let's do npm gun Dev and we do not get
anything here but what exactly is
happening so if I
um try to if I try to open my browser
and if I do and Google host 3001 it is
working but we do not get anything here
that is because the log is set to sign
in so basically you can choose what
messages to see in the logs by using
Google which has four options that are
info one error and second out of which
the default is info if you set it to 1
you will get the warning messages if you
set it to error you get the error
messages and if you get set it to silent
so you will not get any kind of messages
and then
um for now let's set it back to info we
can comment this as well but with that
you can also change the environment
directory
um as as well by using EnV directory
this one
and uh we can maybe set it to the EnV
um and setting the part to that folder
where you have environment variable so
what I mean by that is let's say we have
this environment variable here but uh
maybe I can make a new folder here and
name this the EnV and then again here
make another folder dot EnV copy out of
this paste this here and then type here
new add new so now we have two
environment variables one is this and
one is this
I need to add a comma here so what do
you think which app name and password we
got it this one or this one so let's see
that if I go back here and since we
already have this here and in vgs config
with config.js we said environment
environment directly to the EnV which is
this one and then in that we have NV so
let's see what we get
um if I go to console and uh if I
refresh this this should be
if I do npm1 Dev
oops and BM1 Def
and then go here you flash this now you
can see DB name new DB Pass New so this
means that uh we
set when we set the EnV so it takes the
high priority and whatever values we
have that will be using out of the
environment variables will be taken from
this one let's also try
um app underscore test equals to test
and let's see if this is used so if I
refresh this and if I see we also do not
get that here because now this means
that only the environment for you was
that are presented in this file will be
taken so by default this is um this is
the root folder so which means that
anything that is here that that works so
I will comment this with EnV and yeah
all right
um another thing that we can do here is
let's say I am fed up of running
development npm gun Dev and then going
to my console or going to my browser and
then typing the UI so what I can do here
is I can in the server all in the
preview so what I can do here is
um I can do open and then type
index dot dot HTML and save this so now
in this case if I again do npm gun Dev
it will automatically open uh or start
the server and open the browser for me
so it already open and it opened in in
this tab which is not in the view so
maybe I can try this again and maybe it
shows up here on the screen so if I
again do this and yep you can see this
it automatically switch switch uh the
focus to the Chrome browser and to that
specific tab so and you can also set
this here as well um you can set the
open here as well with index.html or
whatever file you want to use and with
that uh that is those are the basic
commands for those are the basic
configurations for vgs there are many
other configurations which I did not
cover so if in case you are interested
in those you can visit vgs.dev and then
go to config and then here you can find
eye of the configurations so with that
again I just discovered maybe just 10
percent of these um of 15 percent of
these commands so with that that is it
for this section
all right so that is it for this V
tutorial I hope you liked the video If
you do so please make sure to follow me
on other social platforms such as
Twitter and Instagram and give this
video a thumbs up and please make sure
to subscribe to the channel also let me
know what would you want to learn next
are what is something that is missing in
this tutorial and you want me to cover
that as well so hope to see you again in
the next video